alors c'est peut-être une provocation
mais frédéric dabi est ce que marine le
pen n'a pas mis ce week-end des mots sur
une réalité dont les français sont
plutôt plus tôt conscient c'est à dire
qu'il ya une proximité idéologique entre
les électorats front national et les
écoles et l'électorat desjardins pas sur
tous les sujets sur les questions
économiques il ya des vraies différences
sur l'europe mais par contre et sur les
questions identité insécurité
immigration en avait parlé à défaut avec
mon ami jérôme fourquet d'électorat en
fusion maintenant les propos de marine
le pen sont clairement sidérant parce
qu'ils sont en rupture totale avec ce
qu'elle disait ya à peine quinze jours
ce qui a toujours dit par exemple jean
marie le pen face à nicolas sarkozy que
dit le front national lorsque un homme
politique une femme politique de droite
venir braconné pour récupérer des
électeurs de droite passée au fn ou
comme nicolas sarkozy en 2007
faire revenir à droite les électeurs de
jean-marie le pen 2002 le fn dit ce
n'est pas il vous trompe ce qu'il vous
dit il ne le fera pas et quand il sera
au pouvoir et c'est ce qu'a dit marine
le pen ya à peine quinze jours trois
semaines
il fera une politique européiste de
centre-gauche dont est-ce que c'est pas
de signe aussi d'une marine le pen aux
abois qui prouve énormément la parole
dans les médias alors qu'elle n'a rien à
dire je le rappelle qu'elle a annoncé
une consultation des adhérents
frontistes pour février mars
elle est peut-être peut-être sur enfin
c'est un signe supplémentaire de la
crise peut-être personnel et de la crise
que connaît ce parti parce que cette
main tendue ça veut dire quoi
alors c'est un piège peut être un petit
peu trop visible elle ne sera bien sûr
pas relevé par laurent wauquiez qui l'a
bien dit lui veut parler aux électeurs
du front national
mais elle fait un virage à 180 degrés
entre ce discours de tromperie on se
moque de vous et elle propose une
alliance donc ça peut c'est quand même
des propos assez surprenant daniel
bilalian vous croyez